Pues hacer unos cuantos ejemplos más no nos va a hacer nada de daño al contrario.
Entonces vamos a averiguar cuánto vale
25 entre 9
elevado a la potencia 1/2
¿Ok? Esto es equivalente
a decir que estamos buscando,
la raíz cuadrada de 25 entre 9,
así es que estamos buscando un número
que si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 2 veces,
lo que obtenemos es 25/9.
Ahora pues 5 por 5 nos da 25
y 3 por 3 nos da 9.
Entonces pues ¿por qué no intentamos ver si 5/3
es ese número que estamos buscando?
Y bueno, vemos por aquí que 5/3 por 5/3,
aquí lo que tenemos es,
5 por 5 eso es 25
y 3 por 3 es 9.
Entonces sí, si elevamos 25/9 a la 1/2,
lo que obtenemos es 5/3.
¿Ok? Otra forma de pensar en esta multiplicación,
es decir que estamos elevando 5/3
al cuadrado.
Ahora vamos a poner unos números un poquito más complicados, por ejemplo,
81 entre 256,
elevado a la potencia -1/4.
¿Ok? Voy a suponer que ya le pusiste pausa al vídeo
y que ya lo intentaste
y tal vez ya te salió el resultado,
pero bueno, lo primero que haría yo
para encontrar este número sería,
deshacerme de este símbolo de menos,
¿Y qué es lo que estos símbolos de menos
en el exponente hacen?
Pues lo que hacen es que tomemos
el recíproco de este número,
¿Y qué es lo que es el recíproco?
Pues es simplemente 1entre el número.
Ahora 1 entre una fracción es equivalente
a tomar la fracción y voltearla,
así es que esto es exactamente igual a
256 entre 81
elevado a la 1/4,
así es que aquí lo que estamos buscando es un número, que si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 4 veces
lo que nos da es 256,
y otro número que si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo
4 veces nos da 81
¿Ok? Un número que ese número,
por ese número, por ese número, por ese número,
nos de 81
y eso es igual,
lo vamos a ver con todo el detalle del mundo,
cuando veamos las propiedades de los exponentes,
pero eso es exactamente igual a tomar 256
y elevarlo a la 1/4 y tomar 91 y elevarlo a 1/4.
Esto de aquí es igual a esta fracción,
lo vimos cuando estábamos resolviendo este ejemplo. Aquí tenemos que 5 es la raíz de 25
y 3 es la raíz cuadrada de 9,
o sea que 5 es igual a 25,
elevado a la 1/2
y 3 también es 9 elevado a la 1/2 ¿Ok?
Entonces, lo que tenemos que hacer ahorita, es encontrar estos números
¿ok? tenemos que 81 nos puede saltar a la vista, como..
a ver 81 es igual a 9 por 9,
pero a su vez cada uno de estos 9 es igual a 3 por 3, entonces tenemos 3 por 3,
por 3, por 3,
¡y ya! Ya encontramos un número que si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo
4 veces, nos da 8,
o sea, que estamos elevando el 3 a la cuarta potencia.
Así es que 81
es 3 a la 4 y eso lo que implica es que 81
elevado a la 1/4 es igual a 3.
Bueno, pero ahora tenemos que encontrar 256
y resulta que 256 es igual a 4 por 4, por 4, por 4,
y bueno, de hecho podemos multiplicar aquí por un 1, porque no nos afecta en nada,
y el caso es que esto es igual a 4 a la 4.
Así es que 256 elevado
a la potencia 1/4 es igual a 4,
¿Sí? Por que 4 es ese número que si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 4 veces, nos da 256.
Así es que esta fracción de aquí es igual a, a ver el 256
elevado a la 1/4
es esto que encontramos aquí, que es 4...
4...
y 81 elevado a la 1/4
es esto que encontramos aquí, que es 3.
Entonces 81 entre 256
elevado a la potencia -1/4 es 4/3.